different scrutiny of the year and
how to apologies from councilor whittam
and councilor Shirley Proctor I don't
know if you're aware of any more
apologies Alex
apologies have also been received from
councilor Hanby oh no
um
oh right okay are there any Declarations
of interest in any items on the agenda
nope cute and has everybody had a chance
to have a look through the minutes of
the previous meeting
I know are they accepted
yeah
right okay yeah all right
okay I'm not aware of any questions from
the public
and you just come from none have been
received thank you
okay
um I've been asked to um for a slight
change in order on the agenda so
um with everybody's consent could we do
the um absence
um persistence absence as the next item
please
um do we want to do some introductions
before
we start there's one or two new faces
that I don't know so
um my name's Denise Weston I'm a broad
Heath law counselor and I chair this uh
children's grouply committee
um I go that way
hello I'm councilor Joanne Bernice I
represent Selma award
I'm Dave atten I'm a councilor for
course Hill Board
ad councilor Hall and B also for gorse
Hill Ward
I'm Martina mold I'm the pupil absence
team leader in Trafford
uh Karen samples Director of Education
Sarah Butters the head of service for
early years School places and access
Sue Maitland councilor for Dave Hume
West
uh Louise davnell counselor in Priory
reward
Michael Welton councilor in Autry and
Ward
our new Council of a buckler award which
is Partington Carrington and sail west
and Lead member for education
I'm Amy white broad Heathwood
hi I'm Kath Hines I'm the lead member
for children's services
hi I'm Pamela Walton director for early
health and children's social care
you thank everybody I'm Jill McGregor
I'm the corporate director for
children's services
Alex Murray governance officer
Michael whetton councilor for Bowden
Ward and I'm the chairman of Health
scrutiny
thank you everybody
um can we um go on to have a look at
this report is it is it Martina that's
going to present or numbers okay joints
effort thank you for double active
that's okay so
um hopefully you've all had chance to go
through the report but I've pulled
together a few slides to kind of pull
out some of the the main points um that
we want to share with you tonight
um I think first of all
um I just I hope that no one really can
disagree with with this slide as as our
ambition for attendance in Trafford and
the law entitles every child of
compulsory school age and efficient
full-time education and and we know that
by doing that it's Central to raising
standards and particularly those who are
most vulnerable so that they don't fall
behind I think it's also important that
we remember it's a protective Factor as
well to really again help some of our
very young children our very vulnerable
young children and young people
this slide just sort of presents the the
last three years day so we don't have
obviously the date for 2020 because of
the pandemic
um but it just highlights some of the
the key um absence data
um that is really um helpful certainly
for us in determining our strategic
priorities for attendance in in the
local area and you can see there that
actually overall our absence figures
because it is absence figures are above
are below I should say or are better
than National and our statistical
neighbors that's what the SN stands for
uh oh no that's that's fine and that
tends to be
um in the local area anyway it's
Stockport
um also Cheshire East as well is is not
too far from us so actually our children
attend much better than the national and
statistical neighbor data and you can
see then the same applies for the
primary and secondary if you break it
down into those two cohorts too
um as well as our send children as well
you can see certainly the most latest
date to in 2021 and there is a gap for
2019 there because that wasn't published
in in the late document which is where
it's the local Authority interactive
tool
um that I pull this data from but what
we do know is of late uh certainly the
most recent data shows again our young
people with send are attending much much
more than than those um uh than the
National Data would suggest you can see
the two red figures there this is where
our absence is more concerning than our
national and and certainly our
statistical neighbors and that's where I
looked after children and also our child
in need and I think what really is
significant there is you can see that
there's been a significant dip since
2019 so actually the date of the most
recent data is actually quite startling
um for those two cohorts of young people
so clearly um this has probably been a
result of of the last couple of years
the pandemic clearly it's it's really
impacted on on those two cohorts of
young people
what is positive is the extended role of
the virtual school head now
um is going to be I think really
imperative to how we how we really
improve these attendance figures for our
most vulnerable children
um Lindsey Burridge who is our head of
virtual school
um has now been given these extended
roles which is much more of a strategic
leadership responsibility to really
Champion education for our and
attendance for our looks after children
and our children who have a social
worker so that means really making sure
that she's enhancing the Partnerships
between education and children's social
care and really making sure that our
we're all holding those High aspirations
um for our for our children and young
people being able to promote good
practice and sharing of good practice
um in in education also really
supporting identifying what the barriers
are for these children and young people
for not attending and most importantly
for really then thinking about how the
Gap can be can be narrowed and so that
all of our children achieve their
potential I think also as the report
showed there's a role for our Trafford
team together which is being piloted at
the moment in in certainly in Partington
and Stratford and he's due to be rolled
out across the borough attendance is one
of their key performance indicators and
you know they're already saying that
that is a big factor in the
conversations and the meetings that
they're having with schools and the
children and family and and also you
know the the role generally of early
help
so just moving on to the next slide
there I think this is a really powerful
slide actually at demonstrating the
impact of non-attendance
um at school sometimes you know we we
think that well if a child's got 85
attendance surely that's okay but
actually over time when you really look
at the impact that it has on children's
lost learning it's really significant so
even with 95 attendance it's almost two
weeks of lost learning for a child when
you're looking at the 80 attendance you
know that's almost a terms worth of lost
learning where children's attendance is
80 or below and if you think about that
over five years for example at a
secondary school then that's a whole
year of Education that has been lost if
it was 80 attendance over time so I
think it's just such a powerful slide at
demonstrating the impact and what we are
doing is we're sharing these statistics
with our education partners and our
social Care Partners as well to make
sure that we share that that aspiration
and that ambition uh for for higher
attendance but also encouraging schools
to share that with their families too
and with the children and the young
people so again it kind of really brings
it to home and quantifies the impact
that it has because we know that you
know when children are in school clearly
they're learning particularly in the
pandemic they're having to catch up as
well so they really need to need to be
in school but also so we can help
identify these and put the right level
of support around these children too
um this really
um comes from some of the most recent
guidance that the government has has
issued and improving attendance is
everybody's business and that's another
message that we're sharing across the
this the
um system really
um because it's really clear that any
barriers to children not attending
school are really complex you know
they're both within and Beyond the
school Gates and and very often they'll
be specific to individual Children and
Families needs
you know it's really clear that clearly
the people or the children with the
highest attainment whether that be at
the end of key stage two at the end of
primary school or at the end of
secondary school is highest where the
attendance has been highest and you know
it can't it makes sense really but I
think that one of the most important
things is for our most vulnerable
children attendance is also that
protective Factor you know they're in
school they're safe and they're being
provided with the right level of support
um so this this kind of highlights some
of the um information that's actually in
in the DFE report what we do know is
that approximately one in nine children
are persistently absent and again that's
something I know
um certainly the work of Martina and and
the service the attendance service are
really working hard to address is some
of the persistent absence issues where
children are really struggling to to
um to attend school and what we are
finding is that those highest
proportions of persistent absent
children are living in the in the most
deprived areas as well so again that's
where the TTT model as well is and the
early help is going to be really really
important
I think what's disappointing really and
there was a big ass survey that the
children's commissioner did it was
actually in 2021 and disappointingly
children cited unhappiness as a reason
for not attending school
um and you know that that's really quite
worrying the mental health and the
emotional well-being of children is
clearly a significant factor in in
non-attendance
um so this is the guidance that I was
just talking through there that the
government has produced it was just may
this year it's non-statutary guidance
but obviously it's it's probably going
to go through legislation and I think
then Martina becomes statutory for
September 23 so this is something that
we as a in in both children's social
care as well as Education Services and
specifically in the attendance team are
working to see how this is going to be
implemented in Trafford in the local
Authority but also in our schools and it
is very much around
um looking how we can work as a system
together to help prevent intervene and
provide that targeted support so there's
very clear information within that about
what it means for schools what it means
for governing bodies and what it means
for local authorities as well and also
the role of the virtual school so it
outlines it really really clearly and
this really kind of sums up the overview
of the guidance that there is an
expectation that school schools will
manage attendance proactively they'll
look for the trends they'll spot those
patterns and act as quickly as possible
and I think that they try to do that
already
um that we as a system have more
accurate data for our children and our
pupils our schools and our cohorts and
in Trafford that has been a challenge
because we don't have a a an attendance
monitoring system
um that all schools feed into
and certainly during the pandemic
schools were required to submit their
attendance data but the government
didn't didn't say it was mandatory so
again we were very much Reliant upon
those schools that did submit it but
whether there are going to be steps in
Martine or probably provide some
information on that
um to actually make it mandatory that
schools report in to a system that the
DFE will potentially set up
um clearly you know there's a lot of
information around what intervention
schools can make use of when they spot a
particular problem and strategies for
looking at what that evidence-based
interventions look like making sure that
there's expertise both within the
schools as well as the local authorities
as well to provide that one-to-one
support where needed and again looking
at how local authorities as a system can
work together to move those barriers
those out of school barriers and really
work with schools to make sure that the
support is there for our children and
young people
so this just highlights some of those um
bits for schools as I've said
um you know it is about making sure that
relationships are there with families as
well uh that that schools are able to
listen and understand the barriers and
then work with families to remove them
through really targeted plans
um and also support for pupils with
medical conditions or send as well and
really thinking about what adjustments
can be put into place to really break
down some of those barriers and and
enable the children to to attend school
regularly
ofsted actually said in a report in
February 22 and this is something that
we've shared with schools as well you
know about obviously it is about making
sure that you know schools are actively
working to improve attendance and take
different approaches to do so and that
highlighted bit at the bottom I've
studied have been really clear it's
about schools listening understanding
empathizing and supporting but do not
tolerate so there's a very clear message
there that you know schools have got to
be absolutely Relentless in their
pursuit to ensure that children attend
school
what it means for Trafford so in the
guidance it's really clear about what
local authorities are then required to
do and this is something that the team
is working through already
as a minimum this is what we're expected
to do and that goes back to the
rigorously tracking our attendance data
and that that is something we are
looking at developing the eye system
um in in the local uh Authority which
again will make attendance monitoring a
lot more efficient and effective and
I'll certainly enable us to have a much
stronger grip on it strategically
obviously making sure everybody's aware
that it's everybody's business as well
it's not just down to the attendance
team
um again and that goes kind of uh hand
in hand with making it a focus for all
of our Frontline Council services and
certainly at the single service
briefings we're pushing that we're
attending meetings with children's
social Care Partners as well the bridge
conference the with the looks after
children the virtual school held last
week you know we we're finding lots of
opportunities to make sure we really
drip feed these messages
really looking on where we focus our
efforts as well so there will be certain
children certain cohorts certain
localities where we might have to take a
more proactive approach as well
um and also again just making sure that
you know as a local Authority we've got
a real Clear Vision for improving
attendance
and we do have a school attendance
support team in Trafford albeit very
small
um and but there is an expectation that
this team will also provide the core
functions free of charge to all schools
now some of this at the moment we offer
as an SLA so schools pay for it and the
government has said the funding is in
the system so we've just got to find a
way to make sure we can offer this to
all of our schools
um in in a different kind of way and
that's everything around communication
support and and obviously support for
families too so we're already thinking
about how we can capitalize on some of
the work of our associate School
Improvement advisors who are going into
schools every term and making sure
attendance is on their agenda
um as well as how we can work with TTT
and other
um service and other agencies to support
I'm just going to hand over to Martina
now just to go through the legal
interventions as well just so we're
clear about what what that means
um yes
um in terms of legal interventions what
um the grp have made quite clear
actually going forward is that legal
intervention is to be a last resort and
that what we should be doing is
supporting
um ultimately supporting pupils and
families
and basically when those strategies have
all been exhausted then it is then that
you need to put those legal
interventions into place
and there are a few things that have
been mentioned there and just looking at
parenting contracts parenting contracts
um effectively are are issued by schools
with parents and sometimes pupils
signing up to them as well and the local
Authority quite often don't get involved
in them although we can do to formalize
it but sometimes we find that it's
enough for the school just to come
together with the parents and make a
contract as to what well it's at our
expectations it's setting our
expectations both of the parents and of
the school and sort of making clear
um going forward what those targets of
attendance are for for those young
people
um not very many schools are using them
it's more secondary schools that use
them but we think that there's a lot of
value in using parenting contracts so we
are actively trying to encourage their
use as we go forward
because again we think that it is more
of a supportive measure than going down
a legal residual in penalty notices and
prosecutions but it's just got that
little bit of formality
um so that's done really
um as I say in in-house within the
school setting
um the others um are really done on a
local Authority um basis so if we go to
fixed penalty notices first you'll all
be familiar
um with penalty notices we used to use
them as a fast track option in Trafford
um so that when
um attendance was becoming an issue
schools would request a penalty notice
and it would be looked at as an
intervention to stop the attendance
becoming any worse well it sort of
turned on its head really now in terms
of what the DFE have been expecting
um since the pandemic because it's all
part of that support again that
supportive work
um so in terms of penalty notices we
would only issue those as a last
resource except for holidays in term
time
um
so
um effectively they're still going ahead
um on the same basis where if
um if parents have taken the child out
of school they've missed eight sessions
or more of unauthorized absence then a
penalty notice would be issued so um
just looking at the figures you might be
interested in in 2122 we issued 663
penalty notices and 605 of those were
for holidays in term time and only 58
for irregular attendance because we were
already seeing that what we needed to do
was sort of go back to schools and have
them look at right what haven't we done
what can we work at with this family to
avoid going down that Avenue because
penalty notices really it shouldn't just
be a punitive you know for punitive
purposes it should be for trying to make
a difference
in attendance so that's penalty notices
attendance prosecutions and we do we
don't really issue very many attendance
prosecutions per se
um we do issue attendance prosecutions
where penalty notices aren't paid so if
they remain unpaid the penalty notice is
withdrawn
um and we then issue uh or we can at the
school's request issue
um a prosecution for a regular
attendance so they tend to be the ones
that we the cases that we prosecute now
rather than just going for
straightforward prosecution where the
attendance is so bad that we feel as if
we need to take them through the
magistrates court at that point it's
quite a while since we've issued
um a straightforward
um a prosecution without issuing a
penalty notice first to see if the if
the parents would pay it so that already
was being looked at as a last resort
really
um
parenting orders are issued by the
courts
um and that is normally in line with
where where a parent hasn't paid a
penalty notice and it's been withdrawn
and the parents gone to court
um for a regular attendance or as I say
for those prosecutions uh which we just
um take straight away without a penalty
notice so not very often but sometimes
the magistrates would um would order
um that there would be a parenting order
attached um to whatever
um to whatever sentence that they might
decide
um so a conditional discharge or a fine
or they might say right well we want the
parenting order as well and that would
be
um basically defining
um again or into the expectations of
what would be expected of that parents
and the parents in order would normally
last for either 6 months or 12 months
and they would
um the parent has to basically sign up
to things like going to making sure that
they attend parent night and taking an
interest in in the child's education and
improving attendance so um so parenting
orders do have their their uses in terms
of focusing
appearance upon improving attendance but
as I say with it's not really used very
very much at the moment
um
that basically leaves education
supervision orders and I've left it to
last just because
um there is a really big drive for the
introduction of Education supervision
orders throughout
um well basically throughout England and
Wales at the moment
um in Trafford we haven't issued an
education supervision order
um for some considerable time it's been
years really since
um supervision orders
um have been issued it's it's something
that lies with the with the family court
it's not a criminal
um case so
um the and and again I think what's
happened in in the past is used to have
a supervising officer who would
basically
um advise a that's the language that is
used as advising them befriending
um the family and so it's quite an
intensive measure that's used but
and basically
um I've been in traffic since 2006 and I
don't think they've been used I know
they haven't been used since then
um but there is a real Drive
um in line with the
um basically the Support options that
that
the DFE really think that that this
should be happening in schools so we'll
be looking at introducing education
supervision orders in Trafford and
really seeing
um how they can work and again we're
looking
um maybe as a pilot possibly exploring
whether or not we can we can it issue
well we can do the work with an
education supervision or to try and get
the parents in
involved but actually not go down the
legal route
um because it is such a formal procedure
we'll see if we can put it in informally
and see if they can do all of those
things
um that you'd there would be an
expectation for the parents and and the
child
um to do but effectively without that
final Court
um course order but that would be
hanging over them so that if they didn't
comply then they could go go through the
courts
um so that is something that we're
looking at in terms of bringing in
hopefully pretty soon
[Music]
and I think that's it really Whistle
Stop tour thank you okay thank you very
much does anybody have any questions at
all
I thought you mind
cancel the Blackburn
um obviously it's it's disappointing
that absences have have increased since
um since before covid but
I think it's going to sort of take time
for for the statistics to go back to
what we can be considering as normal
um I think one of the um
so since that worrying things are the
the persistent absences one one in nine
um within that can it can ask um is
there any evidence that if if a child or
a young person lives with separate
parents on separate days is there any
increase in absenteeism
we haven't really done anything specific
around sort of you know deep diving into
that statistically
um but it is something that well
potentially what we're going to be doing
with the now that we've got more access
to the data
um is we'll be able to do that deep
diving
um really and this is sort of there are
all of these things obviously is really
worrying to us as well why the PA
figures have increased but there's not
only that there's also now severely the
DFE have got a new category of Civic
called severely absence which is 50 and
less so we're sort of concentrating on
that as well
um so there's there doesn't seem to be
anything that sort of stands out where
we could where we could identify that
kind of that particular cohort
um but you know there's quite a few
things really that we need to look into
in terms of what causes that PA I think
just on the back of that Council of
Blackburn we do have um call it the
karmi group don't we and then obviously
um you know the as we were just talking
about the severely absent group where we
do look at the children and young people
who have got attendance uh less than 80
60 and so on and so forth both a Martina
chairs that and what you do do is bring
together all the multi-agencies so
whatever the reasons might be whether it
they are split families or whether they
are there are young people with
emotionally based school non-attendance
as well they've got real anxiety
problems and it's looking at again it's
it's really honing down into the
individual pupils actually and really
identifying again as a system what can
we do to you know to wrap around the
support for these children and young
people one of the things that we've been
piloting as well is the av1 robots
and we actually the av1 robots we I
think we use them over covid didn't we
Martina and we bought some and and we
kind of loaned them out to schools and
that was an opportunity basically the
robots are in the school if you like
these little little robots
um and they are actually allowing the
children who are at home to access the
classroom learning it was a beautiful
example from Wellington actually of a
young person who couldn't get out of the
bedroom but they were still able to
access the learning through the av-1
robot and it and it's it's making sure
that children can still engage in their
learning hopefully then build back some
of that well-being and that esteem and
support them back into into the
classroom and um I know some schools
have gone on to purchase them for
themselves as well so there's lots of
really kind of Creative Solutions to
helping those children who are
persistently absent yeah the reason I
asked the question is when I was
teaching I had a little girl in one of
my classes and she lived with the other
parents each weekend
and that parent had an issue trying to
get because they didn't didn't live in
the borough getting the child to school
um that time and it was only afterwards
when we realized what was happening that
some something could be done and I think
that the new sort of responsibilities
for schools there will be an Ask of
schools to really be clear about what
what the context is for these individual
children and families and how then
whether it's referral into services or
whatever that support might look like to
just really you know make sure that
children are able to access education
sometimes um if I can sorry if I just
come in on that sometimes um it will
become clear when a parent sorry when a
school requests a penalty notice and
then we look into
um what information they've provided and
we look at the pattern of absence and
it's exactly that what that you've
described
um and so what we do then is we would we
would go back to the school and say can
you find out a little bit more about
that because that pattern is tending to
suggest that
um you know it might be that they need
some more supportive work rather than
just go for a penalty notice so
sometimes that's how it can come to our
attention
um and then we would say others
um maybe try some more supportive
measures possibly thank you so I've got
counselor Hines and then Council of
Admiral also has a question hi yeah I'll
be really brief it's not a question it's
just more of a comment actually
um we've had a really good discussion
today in the startwell board around the
potential impact of the cost of living
crisis on children and families and and
understanding that picture of the
impacts of of covid I think we've got
that emerging picture but I don't think
we yet know what the impacts of the cost
of living crisis is going to be on
children and families and I think it's
worth kind of
noting and
um and monitoring really whether cost of
living crisis starts to have an impact
on School attendance and for all those
things that we foresee may happen in
terms of the impact on health for
children and but also around whether
children can actually get to school
um and
um and and whether actually there may be
some impact on well-being of parents and
all those sorts of things so I think
it's worth definitely monitoring over
the coming months as we're going into
the winter whether there is any any kind
of further impact on on attendance
foreign
yeah um I I totally agree um in terms of
our Kami work which Karen just mentioned
before it's
um Children at Risk of missing education
um group that um that meets every month
and we
um there's a a range of agencies we meet
together and we identify those children
who've got very very poor attendance
they might have come to our attention
um schools might have raised them we've
also got um young people on the list
that schools haven't raised but we can
see that there's been a you know a real
dip in their attendance and we look at
the data from the term before
um because that's the most accurate data
that we can look at
um but we also monitor um how that
attendance is going with the ones that
we've highlighted um in the current
period so we can do a comparison and
that's something that my team have
actually
um we've already reflected upon
um the cost of living crisis and what
that might mean so for instance tomorrow
we do have our first calming meeting of
the new Academic Year and it's it is
something one of the factors that would
that we will actually be looking into
along with everything else that we do
thank you
hi you'll have to forgive me because I'm
a little bit out of date with my
terminology so
um You probably get where I'm going to
so
um as you've pointed out it is really
difficult to sort of pull apart
um absence
and other circumstances so those things
are all very much wrapped up together
deprivation difficult circumstances
mental health etc etc so what I was
wondering was uh you did touch upon it
there actually how many of the children
who are identified by schools
um as being consistently absent or have
increasing absence are already known to
you sort of already established as
children in need or whatever you we are
up to these days
um were as good as the data that we have
um and and by that I mean that um
Schools sign up to
um what we call group call and that way
we can track the data
um they schools also Harbor statutory
responsibility to return to us to the
local Authority
um uh those students who have been
continuously absent for 10 days or more
so we do actually have that that data
that does come in
um to us
um both
it's so we we know quite a lot of the
children I would say that are
persistently absent but there are still
those that we know that we haven't that
we we don't know of
um and that's with and what we do about
that is Chase schools who don't sign up
to the data collection so that we can
find out that information because that
that is an issue I mean we we do have um
at the moment we've got around
um 400 children who were lucky who were
specifically looking at who are
um
65 percent and under
attendance and that's the group that
were sort of really focusing on now
um but we do have
um we basically track the 90 on unders
as well
um so we've got sort of one officer
who's who looks at that particular
um cohort and sort of just highlights if
there might be problems for instance
um some schools might have a higher
um that they might just be coming up
with a higher level of persistent
absence than usual
um so we be able to sort of track that
and maybe just make that inquiry of the
school is there anything happening or
more people
it tends to be sometimes that people are
going on holiday that for instance post
covered that's been a real thing where
people have taken advantage of going on
holiday because they can and so that's
created quite a lot of persistent
absence but as the year goes on
um then that sort of usually flattens
out
yeah
so
um
I don't expect pin this down now so I'm
just thinking if if you already know of
an established cohort of children that
you're already aware of that already
under your auspices and you know that
they have
um poor attendance in schools
um can you sort of identify the things
that those children have in common I
mean I'm guessing we could guess at them
but you know is there a list of things
that will just go these kids have got
this issue this issue this is this issue
we might expect this to happen so we
could look at earlier interventions and
that's something that I'm just
interested to know I mean I I come from
a teaching background but actually
across the way in Salford and as you can
imagine it um
absence was a particular issue for a lot
of the schools there so I'm also
wondering whether or not there's any
communication with schools who are on
our borders who might have had these
problems going on for a lot longer like
Manchester and Salford uh I think
Trafford generally speaking we don't
have quite
um
I think we have examples of all the
issues that any area has but we might
not have had them in such numbers that
have drawn to our attention so like
you've already pointed out to us these
these have gone up significantly
recently I'm also thinking of the stuff
that's available in schools and also
thinking of how schools
would be funding things so
my experience of working in Salford was
that most of the schools I had anything
to do with had welfare officers now that
comes up that comes within the schools
on the school staff and I appreciate
that that comes out of school budgets
but they are at that desperate position
where that is a place they've had to go
to so I'm looking at um thinking about
whether or not there will be schools
particularly if you're going to focus if
you find that there's a local particular
issue whether that is something that you
feel schools could fund themselves or
whether we would have to find the extra
money to help them with that because
that seems to me to be a really good
link and particularly when you were
talking probably to go on but um
particularly when you're talking about
um the formal arrangement of
um the education supervision order to me
that person in school with that constant
daily contact and the now and the time
to communicate with you would be the
ideal person but I can see that it might
be a long way off because financial
situation so I just want to know how you
feel about that and I think that's
probably where the DFE guidance is going
to so it's really clear about what the
responsibility is for schools what the
responsibility is for the local
authorities what the responsibility is
for the governing bodies I mean
education Welfare Offices e-wo's we used
to have that as a service it was a paid
for service in Trafford but it wasn't
financially viable so we had to get rid
of the service we it was just carrying a
debt
um now straight away when this guidance
has been released the schools were
saying so does that mean we're going to
get anywhere again and we said no
you're going to have to it goes back to
you it's your responsibility if you want
you know you can buy one you can pay for
one you can seek one you can Source One
yourself
um it's not you're right we've got we've
got to find
really kind of Creative Solutions about
how we tackle this as a service as well
because there isn't any additional
funding around this what we have to do
is is utilize things like the early help
like the Trafford team together
um opportunities
um working with our children's social
care colleagues because social workers
are working with these families day in
day out to really think about how they
can support and identify barriers to
attendance and it's not going to give us
any additional resource into the team so
again we've just got to really work
together on on you know how we work as a
system I think the important thing as
well is attendance won't fix overnight
it's not it's not an overnight fix you
know this is something that you know is
we've got to identify what those
barriers are children won't just choose
not to go to school you know and we're
having to say to schools as well you
can't just you know you know issue a
fixed penalty notice because you think
that's going to make a difference you
know children won't attend for whatever
reason that might be so it's really
understanding what those barriers are
and and that's where those reasons
that's where the karmi group is really
effective at saying this is what we know
about the child in the family and this
is how we can work together to help so
uh I know in the secondary schools they
used to have a year ahead who's somebody
that perhaps a social worker or
yourselves could speak to reasonably
what I'm saying I know teachers are
quite difficult to get hold of because
they're quite often in class aren't they
so the advantage of schools
um having that person in place who who
looks at that side of things is that
also they're available to put that time
and effort in it it's too much to put
onto the teacher so it is so I'm
wondering about going forward whether
we're going to look at perhaps look at
some sort of best practice model for
schools where you could make
recommendations to them and look perhaps
even at something like shared staff
because then you've got somebody with a
good range of knowledge and that's
that's kind of what the guidance is
going through yeah the the guidance is
basically saying that schools now will
have to identify an attendance Champion
or a designated attendance person uh in
every in every school and the way we see
it is is working with that person is
that partnership working that really
important multi-agency partnership
working as you've pointed out really to
identify who is best placed to help that
particular family and you know be behind
all the data and we spend a lot of time
trying to work data and figures and
everything but behind every figure
because we always have to remember that
there's a child in the family there that
needs that support and suppose that's
the challenge that we've got so the data
is usually quite easy for schools to
come across isn't it to do Sims things
like that you know it's quite easy to to
pull out that data and look I'm thinking
also of um so in the last school I was
at for example the welfare office they
would occasionally go and pick up
children from home and he happens to be
on that point
um we had a walking bus
um and that's what a lot of our schools
are already doing and we were looking at
informal mentoring from parent to parent
um to just call around and see the
wedding or whatever yeah so do you think
there will become a point where we have
some sort of Guidance just so that we
know we know retargeting what best
practice is I know it will be an
ever-evolving thing because hey
everything changes every 20 minutes
anyway doesn't it but yeah I'm just
interested to know
um that we are giving out really good
advice that is really accessible and
that it isn't somebody on the phone to
you all the time asking you the same
questions over and over again and that
was as a committee we kind of know what
the recommendations were and then we've
got something to look at whether it's
healthy Norman as well and I think this
is where the role of the virtual school
comes in as well because they have got
that remit now so the head of the
virtual school has got that increased
responsibility for the most vulnerable
children so that is he looked after and
it is those children who have ever had a
social worker as well as those child in
need child protection
um they've got a really clear
responsibility now for championing
education and championing attendance in
school so Lindsay is already analyzing
the data she's already recruited a Data
Tracking officer to work alongside the
attendance team as well to track to
literally she Rings up and check others
children in and so we're really having
those engaging conversations with
schools but also then it is establishing
those communities a good practice so we
will have schools already that have got
exceptional attendance and will have
schools where we know they haven't and
we've got to work out why one of those
children schools with a similar cohort
well that's that's it it's working out
why it's is it you know is it to do with
tolerance levels is it to do with the
profile of the young people or you know
what because sometimes there are there
are we also have inclusion profiles as
well where we can see where the most
vulnerable children attend school and
actually there are some schools in the
most deprived areas who have fabulous
attendance data and some that should
have much better attendance data as well
so the role of the school Improvement
officers when they go in on a termy
basis is really kind of challenging the
attendance data to and what you're doing
about it actually it's not good enough
what is your strategy in school to
really make sure you're promoting
attendance so we've got a bit of a
challenge as well as support as well as
that sharing of good practice thank you
I'm just conscious of the time
um and I've got councilor Welton
councilor Maitland
councilor Blackburn and councilor Acton
so um
can we start with councilor Welton yeah
very quickly um just do ee formal esos
have a cost implication for us
I don't know the formal ones
and then are we going down the informal
route are we saving ourselves some money
at the same time and if you don't I mean
if we can sort it out that way
um but
um in terms of
Effectiveness there's a lot of
authorities that have been doing pilot
projects because I don't think there are
many many local authorities who have
been issuing Education certification
workers over the years to be honest so
it's sort of learning new and the
authorities that have been using them of
weeks and times have really reported a
good success rates
in terms of its impact
[Music]
that's formal ones rather than informal
ones
or both right okay yeah
right
I've got sometimes it can't be so
um but I do know that it were um
informal esos have been then formalized
um
then because they
um because they didn't reach that all
but there will be
um
consequence
thank you councilor Maitland what was
your question
um
oh I do apologize thank you
um there's 42 schools
um you've got a new figures here with 42
children and those 42 children from
those 42 schools or
chat I think I think it it will be those
out of the schools that were involved in
TTT right 42 of the children will have
been identified as ones who have
attendance as a as a challenge as an
issue okay yeah
um how's this progressing then this this
TTT
so at the moment and and Jill and Pamela
might want to come in at this stage but
at the moment
um it's we've we've got it in place in
Partington in the north and we
purposefully started there just because
that's where we know there is an area of
need
um and we're not calling it a prototype
anymore because it is the way of working
it's what we're absolutely passionate
about with a plan to roll that out
across South and Central uh hopefully
then we'll get it across for a bike and
in March April next year
no if it would help
um I'm happy to come in on that so as
Karen said if we started learning from
elsewhere so it's a tried and tested
model that has been that has a strong
evidence base through the DFE
Innovations program and as Karen's
articulated it's a way of working it's a
way of being rather than a discrete
service so actually it's bringing all of
our Collective Services together across
the whole of the children's partnership
and working in and through schools to
identify what's the need whose best
place to provide that and we're now in
the process of rolling that out across
the borough very much as part of our
family help because we're moving away
from the concept of early help to talk
about the help that families need across
we've had some evaluation of it not
independently evaluated but we've had
some evaluation of this and it's proving
to be really successful
um so it's part of that holistic offer
that was one of my questions as well
have we got any figures of positive
outcomes I'm really sorry oh no don't
apologize it's it's good that people are
asking the question um I've not I was
going to say I've Not got figures of the
of those necessarily those positive
outcomes but it might be that we can
share the evaluation report that we've
already has been produced from TTT and
trafficking together and as it's rolled
out we you know it might be something
that we share at this Committee in
future yeah yeah cancel that then
thank you we've obviously talked about
the education of our children young
people but the the other thing is
particularly second secondary um people
if they're not in school there's more
chance of them engaging in crime or
being exploited and we want them to be
safe so it's something that we obviously
need to consider
I completely agree and that's that point
about attendance being a protective
Factor as well not just about outcomes
so completely agree counsel about them
absolutely and finally councilor
accident did you have a question
yeah I mean I think firstly I just
wanted to uh thank you for bringing this
to us and
um and I I know that it's
um a really difficult issue for I think
all of our schools and a lot of time is
taken up in terms of just trying to get
young people to to to to school so you
know I I think they do
a fantastic job in relation to that but
I just had a one specific point that I
wanted to ask about
um and that is
um you know there are certain
circumstances for which absence can be
permitted and I'm sure that that can be
stretched into some of those issues of
bullet point and I think
um one that I would highlight would be
the the Gypsy traveler family it's with
no fix Abode who are required to travel
um yeah who is required to travel for
for work that day meaning the child
cannot attend the usual School
and
how do you actually monitor that
and I say that because I think
um as we know you know individuals can
actually
make the stats really bad for a school
if one individual or two individuals or
just a few individuals you know are
abusing the sort of system and getting
away with it and and and that actually
um is detrimental to to the to to the
school so
um yeah I my comment on that would be
that
um we we do advise schools because quite
quite often they will come to us and ask
us the question can we code
um can we code it as authorized absence
if um if someone is is away as you say
um and the the law does allow for relief
of absence but it's it's really
important that that's not abused so
sometimes
um well on occasions we will just try
and get as much information that we can
um and we have advised schools to do
home visits
um where we feel that perhaps it isn't
all that it that it it's being presented
as we say really you go you go into need
to sort of look at that in more detail
and come back to us and then we'll
basically be able to advise you as to
whether or not you should be challenging
whether that child should be in school
because sometimes we find that people
will hide behind
um you know reasons what they think they
can get away with it
um and so we're always or should we say
um trying to be a as a were as possible
of those sort of situations where people
are um maybe abusing that or trying to
and just trying to find the real reasons
be behind it because
um the other thing that we would always
do with with Travelers is basically we
would we're trying to explain the
purpose of Education how important it is
um to receive an education you know
wherever that family may be we'd say you
know you should be enrolled in the local
school or whatever that that might be
um so you know we do have that
conversation we try and keep
um well we encourage schools
um to come to us so that we can advise
them on whether or not we feel there
should be a challenge or not I'd say
thank you and very very last question
counselor Hornby I just wanted to ask
know you mentioned that we don't have a
monitors to monitoring systems software
um and the process is quite manual is
this something we could get and if so
what's preventing us from getting this
well we we are getting the system
um so we have got a system which is
group call
um as I say uh it's free to schools but
for some reason some schools will not
share their data with us
um and and we've we've gone back to them
and said please you know can you but you
know it it it's not always happening
we've got about three quarters of the
schools who submit the data
um the eye system is going to allow us
actually it's a much simpler one that
pulls down from Sims which is those
internal systems that school has so it's
much easier at pulling the data in and I
think it'll help with uh oversight of
reports and so on
um so we are getting to that system but
again we're just Reliant upon schools
being willing to share so we're looking
at data sharing agreements and so on and
with them but to kind of protect against
that mitigate that risk as well as it
goes back to the Tony visits we have
with schools with school leaders through
our associate School Improvement
advisors where we're actually going into
the school to talk about all sorts of
things curriculum but it's an
opportunity for us to say talk about
your attendance why aren't you sharing
it with us what is it looking like show
us the figures what is it like for those
different groups and what are you doing
about it so there's lots of
opportunities for us to to get into
those conversations as well
and I think if I could just come in on
that I think I think our big hope as
well is the DFE are currently having a
pilot running a pilot system
um and uh in Trafford we've got about 65
schools that have signed up um to that
dfe's data collection system we're
hoping that um as time goes on that that
will become mandatory for schools to do
that that will make a massive difference
to us in terms of data collection
um because the local Authority does have
access to it so I I can already see that
system I can already extract more data
now this year than I've ever been able
to extract before
um so that's a really really positive
position
um but we just need to encourage
everybody to sign up because it's
obviously only as accurate
um as as the numbers that you've got
signed up thank you thank you thank you
for the report and thank you for such
comprehensive then answers that well
prepared and you're welcome to stay or
leave as you wish thank you very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
there
oh okay so I'm going to move on to
um the school Place planning and
sufficiency I know this has been a big
issue this year
um particularly in the south of the
borough so we have had sight of the
report
um if you could give us an overview of
the report
um I don't think we need to go through
it sort of line by line that's okay I'll
give the um
committee more chance to ask questions
thank you
uh yeah no problem
um I'm just going to run through a few
slides Which pull out some of the key
themes from the report
um this first slide just highlights the
overview in the governance for school
Place planning in Trafford so we have
two boards of school places board
um which has a range of Education
membership we also have a play shaping
board which pulls in wider colleagues
from strategic planning development
legal in Estates and that's where all
the strategic planning for school place
is takes place
and thinking about our approach we have
a statutory annual return that we have
to make to the department for Education
which is known as the scap or the school
capacity survey and the school capacity
survey it looks at the supply and the
demand for school places and it's the
figures that we input into that survey
that DFE used to calculate our basic
need funding which is the funding that
we received to expand schools and create
additional places
um so we submit this each year but there
is a lag between when we submit it and
when that generates funding for
um in the last 12 years we've received
78 million pounds worth of basic need
funding and that has been invested to
expand 29 different schools and creating
an additional you know over three and a
half thousand additional places and
we've also been identified in Trafford
as an Exemplar local Authority in terms
of achieving
um effective and efficient use of the
funding
an important point is in the dfe's scap
survey
um it assumes that every local Authority
will provide a place for every child
that wants one in our area and so that's
what we have to submit in in the scap
survey but that is slightly different to
our local sufficiency assessment so when
we think about our statutory Duty that's
to provide a place for every child
that's residents in Trafford rather than
every child that just wants a school
place in Trafford
um within our local sufficiency modeling
we do aim to retain a minimum five
percent Surplus and that's to
accommodate the usual patterns of in-ear
applications that we see and parental
preference
and there's a lot of detailed
partnership work that takes place to
make sure that the impact of new Housing
Development is mitigated you can see
here um in the last sort of 18 months to
two years we have secured just over two
million pounds of section 106 education
contributions for primary and then
nearly half a million pound for
secondary and there's also a lot of
strategic work which is taking place so
when we look at some of the large
strategic land allocations in the places
for everyone plan like at timpley wedge
and new Carrington we're very much
factoring in that that is going to
generate
um significant additional demand for
school places and we have identified a
land allocation at simply wedge with an
option to create a new Primary School
there that would be phased for 2028 I
think really importantly one of our
strategic priorities in Trafford has
always been to expand the existing
School estate that's really important to
protect the financial viability of our
existing schools so the department for
education for example will no longer
create single form entry school because
it's very difficult for that school to
remain financially viable
we also secured land at the case site
for provision of a new primary school if
that was needed although it has recently
been agreed that we will be better
meeting the need in that area from
existing School expansions and what that
site is now under consideration for a
potential new special school bid
just wanted to highlight that we have
received quite a large number of
applications from families from Ukraine
that are being hosted in Trafford so
we've had 92 applications so far and
we've placed 80 children so that's 51 in
primary and 29 in secondary and we are
potentially expecting more children to
be placed but the initial sort of Spike
or surgeon demand for the from the
Ukraine families has slowed down now
um the government made it really clear
there was no specific additional
priority for Ukrainian children but what
we do have is a fair access protocol so
the fair access protocol is almost like
the safety net that we use to place
vulnerable children who have not been
able to achieve a place in our area and
so we use it for a variety of different
vulnerable groups which does include
Asylum Seekers and and it's also used
for any in-ear applicants who have been
unable to achieve a place because places
aren't available so for those in-ear
applicants the fat protocol allows us to
allocate places over number
so first of all if we just quickly go
through the primary school sufficiency
on National offer Day this year and also
last year in 2021 traffic had sufficient
places for the main round of entry into
reception that was in all areas of
Trafford and there was a surplus in
every area
and the percentage of applicants offered
first preference was strong 93.4 in 2021
up to 94 in 2022 so that exceeds the
England
statistic
Trafford is the admission Authority for
half of our primary schools but it does
coordinate in-year admissions for all
schools including the schools we're not
the admission Authority for and that is
by written agreement from all of those
schools we've always experienced a
unique pattern of inbound migration in
Trafford into our primary schools and
that's into the upper year group so
usually yeah five year six and that's
families that move here ready to access
our quite unique selective education
system
what we've seen in the last 18 months
though is an unprecedented increase in
demand from in-ear applicants across all
primary year groups and that's created
significant pressure in the system
so thinking about that surge it started
in summer 2021 so that is well after our
scap 21 pupil forecast was submitted to
the DFE and between May and October we
usually receive around 435 in-ear
applications but in 2021 we received
more than double that 991 applications
and that has just created really
significant pressures across the system
and that increased demand has continued
through the school year so through the
last school year 21-22 and when we kind
of look at before the pandemic on
average in Trafford we received around
909 primary and year applications and
for the last school year that was up 56
to 1414.
so the pressures are incredible and I
just really want to highlight that you
know the team are working so hard to
deal with these applications and to to
place children as best we can in local
schools
this is the rug rating for primary
sufficiency so we split it up into place
planning areas and we also split it up
into lower year groups and upper year
groups so upper ear groups this key
stage two the lower ear groups as early
years and key stage one
so we've got some pressure
um in the alteringham area in the upper
year groups which is what we often see
and that's
potentially linked to people coming in
to access the selective education system
we have implemented quite a lot of
expansions permanent and temporary
expansion measures in it in altering
them and that has meant an improved
position in terms of the rag ratings
we've got green now for the lower year
groups
sale East and sail west remains very
problematic we've got no vacancies in
pretty much any Air Group in any school
in in sale so they are rugrated red
and then there is some pressure in lower
ear groups in the urmston area but it's
quite localized to specific year groups
and then the rest of Trafford for
primary is green
[Music]
we've got a number of permanent
expansion projects which are going
through at the moment
um in sale altering um and also
wormstone these were at different stages
of progress and they are subject to
completion of all the statutory
processes that's creating an additional
665 places in total
we've also had to look more broadly at
different measures that we can we can
use to try and meet this really
significant increased demand for a near
places
so the ha on occasion we have had to
place children further away than we
usually would from their local school
and if they are overstocked through
walking distance then we would fund a
travel pass to make sure that Financial
there isn't a financial uh barrier there
for the family
we also did an audit of all the existing
specialist spaces in our primary schools
and we have converted some of those
spaces into additional classrooms so you
can see there there's quite a lot of
projects that have been carried out in
both sale and altering him to create
additional bulge classes so we've got
Bulls class at warates we've got some
places from our permanent expansion
projects that have been brought online
early
um
and that is how we have continued to be
able to meet the demand
if we move on to look at secondary
sufficiency that unprecedented increase
in demand went on to have really
significant pressures into those
families that were transferring into
Secondary School in 2022
um a national offer day we only just had
enough capacity to offer a place to
everyone that had applied for one and we
had 179 children primarily in the
ultimate sale area who couldn't be
allocated a place at a preferred school
and so they had to be allocated a place
at a nearest school with a vacancy
so at the end of the allocation process
every school across the whole of
Trafford was full and some schools had
allocated over the published admission
number
um
in terms of being able to meet parental
preference 84.7 of applicants were
offered one of the first three
preferences so that is below the England
figure
and then really importantly the system
is very fragmented when we look at the
secondary sector so Trafford is only
actually the admission Authority for one
of our 19 secondary schools and we do
not have coordinated in-ear admissions
what we have done more recently is
channeled all in-ear applications for
secondary through our Central portal on
the council website to give us better
oversight of what the position is for
in-ear applications in the secondary
sector
and you can see there again we don't
monitor the number of applications but
we do have a census proxy which
indicates that in your new starters in
secondary is up 41 in the last school
year when we compare it to an average
year pre-pandemic
this is the rug rating for the secondary
sector
um it's it's read all across Central and
South neighborhoods
um Stratford is Amber for the lower year
group screen for the upper year groups
um urmston read in the lower ear groups
Amber in the upper year groups and then
Partington again it's red so we really
are full to bursting point across the
majority of our secondary schools
so the DFE indicate that we need to
create 607 New mainstream places but
that is based on the scap 21 data it's
really important we appreciate that
because the position has significantly
changed since then we have created 200
additional places at bth which means
based on the scap-21 calculation so it's
still about 407 places to provide
and we have been exploring a range of
options but we do have a lot of
challenges with our Secondary School
estate most of them are on small sites
we have challenges with the existing
communal facilities which makes it very
difficult to identify options for
expansions
so we progressed three potential options
here astronaut mersey we looked at me
providing a sixth form and a nearby site
to unlock space on the main site but
that turned out to not be feasible and
then we're awaiting
um we've commissioned Architects to
deliver us feasibility studies for north
gastrian and alteringham college and
we're waiting for those back they are
due very soon and once we've got the
results from those that will be
presented as options to traffic
executive
or the things that we've done to try and
support the sufficiency challenges and
to be able to place children is we
already have many schools that are
taking over number when we place
children Through the Fair access
protocol invariably that is meaning that
there are more children being placed
above published our mission numbers we
know that all our neighbors are full and
we are considering if there are any
options to create temporary bulge
classes in our secondaries but it's a
lot more challenging than it is for a
primary school it's not simply a case of
creating one additional temporary
classroom because we kind of have those
operational challenges for schools with
planning for Teacher time and planning
for specialist space use
we've considered whether any of our
existing schools could deliver from a
satellite site but we haven't
um you know we know that that's not
worked well in other local authorities
that have tried delivering schools from
non-education facilities
um a really key part
um
of
the strategy has been to try and
encourage all parents that are due to
transfer to secondary school to utilize
all five preferences on their
application form and to make sure that
they include all local school choices
and that is the only way really that we
can protect places for Trafford
residents because if a Trafford parent
doesn't apply for a place but an out of
borough parent does then they're always
going to be allocated the place we can
only allocate to Trafford parents um if
they express the preference
we have seen a shift when we look at
that strategy
um
we noticed it was largely successful in
terms of pushing non-trafford residents
out of our non-selective schools so we
still have large proportions of children
in our selective schools that are from
out of Trafford but with the advice that
we gave to parents and the fact that
most parents did follow that advice we
only offered to eight non-trafford
residents compared to 79 the year before
so we've pushed a lot of Manchester
residents back over into Manchester
local Authority
we have also seen a small shift in the
number of places that were offered in
grammar schools to Trafford residents so
it's a small shift but it is a shift and
Improvement for us when we look at the
sale and alteringham areas we secured 70
of places in selective schools for
Trafford residents which is up two
percentage points on lost time which was
68 percent
so we're at the point now where we know
we've got to create additional places
and since we've submitted our most
recent scap and which is the scap 2022
We believe We Now can evidence enough
additional demand to explore a new
school
so there are two routes for opening a
new school which are described on this
slide here the centrally funded route
Trafford does not qualify for because of
its educational outcomes being positive
so government focuses their investment
on the education investment areas so
that excludes Trafford
and then what usually happens is there's
a presumption free school route so where
we have
sufficiency uh shortfall of places
we would be expected to go down the
presumption routes and the local
Authority would be expected to fund all
capital costs for building the new
school and also provide a new site
now due to the unique and unprecedented
position that we find ourselves in we
have been able to formally Express an
interest with the DFE for a new
Secondary School
it usually requires evidence demand for
a sixth form Entry School but the DFE
have
um permitted us to consider
a smaller school so we are considering
the possibilities of opening a five-form
entry Secondary School somewhere in sale
or alteringham areas so there's work
underway to identify any potential sites
so that's one of the biggest challenges
I'm sure you can imagine it's a very
large site requirement for a secondary
school it requires outdoor space and so
there was a workshop today where people
from the planning and development teams
were going through to identify sites
um if the bid for the new school is
successful the timeline that we will be
looking at it'll be three years
I think that's the end of the slides
um
really informative
um I know
I've been bombarded by residents this
time particularly about the secondary
school places it does concern me that 30
of the selective education schools are
going to out of borrow children because
if 100 went to our own children
that would have a you know an a knock
down effect wouldn't it
um and but we can't do anything about
that unfortunately does anybody have any
questions
I thought you might yeah of course yeah
first of all I just wanted to say thank
you so much for all the work you did for
the Ukrainian children coming over I
quite a lot in my ward and you were just
fabulous with all of them I just
wondered um
as a lot of them are coming to the end
of their six-month stays the likelihood
is that at least a proportion of them
will have to move on uh which may keep
them in Border or may move them out of
borough so I are you anticipating
um
um accommodating children in moving
schools or would that perhaps come down
to you providing that financial support
for children to get to the schools that
they've already established at if they
need to move their home base
I think if they move out of Trafford
then it is no longer a responsibility to
place those children but they would
still have the option to retain the
school place they're in now if that was
the will of the family and so I guess at
this stage it's it's quite difficult to
know what families will will want to do
so we're not particularly anticipating
movement but it could it could happen
right well it's just I have those sort
of queries are starting to just pop up
now
um in terms of accommodation so I
imagine that they will translate into
school places reasonably quickly but
then we will all know thank you anyway
you've been really good up to now
sorting things out for them thank you
councilor Welton
thank you um
a couple of questions so the first one
uh you can put five you can select five
schools when you're applying for for
Secondary School
just limiting it to five cause any
problems if it was seven or eight then
people could put down all the grammar
schools that they want to put down and
then put five five more schools down is
would that in any way help our situation
um you know in terms of enabling people
to put down more local schools with
confidence and therefore more likely to
get into a local school
um it's something that we could consider
in the statutory guidance there's a
requirement for us to offer a minimum of
three preferences and many local
authorities just offer the three
preferences so we've already gone higher
than that by offering five in Trafford
um when we experienced a delay in the
grammar school results
um enjoying the pandemic we actually
increased that and offered eight
preferences what we find now though is
most families do get their grammar
school results prior to having to submit
your application for secondary and so
unlike during the pandemic where the
results were delayed and the
applications had to be submitted before
the results
um five seems to be working for families
one of the difficulties we have is
getting families to express five
preferences and and some families you
know and applicants if they absolutely
do do not want to go to a particular
school they're not going to put that
school as a preference so not everybody
utilizes those five preferences
already
and I think just just coming in on that
you know that
we recognize we're going to be pressures
in particular in the alteringham area
didn't we Sarah and that was where that
written communication to families
encourage them to do just that you know
fill every box because otherwise you
will not get a school of your choice
um and I you know we we wrote to parents
literally they had a letter through the
door as well as emails as well as on our
website and we've continued to do that
again this year just being really clear
about please you know make sure that
you're you know you you're not just
putting down all the grammars and then
you know maybe one one school after that
um in in the local area or you're only
putting the grammars or as Sarah said
you've just been extremely selective
about where your children go because
otherwise you will be placed in a school
where there are vacancies and and that's
you know we have tried to really push
that message and we're pushing it
through our primary colleagues as well
to make sure families are are aware of
the situation
thank you um
thank you
um
4.2
um it says that the cost of providing a
permanent School place in Trafford is
lower than the national figure could you
comment on that
uh yes so that is linked to the cost the
capital costs of creation of a new place
so the analysis takes place nationally
as part of the school places scorecard
by the DFE and they look at how much
it's cost us to create so many school
places in Trafford through our expansion
projects and then they compare that to
other local authorities and how much per
place it's cost them so it's it's the
capital cost of of the physical
expansion rather than any Revenue costs
of delivering a place
councilor Bennett thank you do you have
any data as to how many children are
still waiting to be allocated a place
and how long is it from the first plane
before the receiver place
so we have just recently had Fair access
protocol meetings for both secondary and
primary and so the only people left in
the system that are awaiting a place of
people who have very very recently
applied so I think um the primary fap
was last week and we had around 10
outstanding cases all in the sale area
but all those children have now been
placed the places may not have started
that might happen next week the
secondary fap we we had 40 odd children
that went to the fap and they have now
all been placed
so there isn't anybody who has been
waiting so we had quite a large amount
of inbound applications over the summer
period
and that that was the kind of large
numbers that we've been placing we've
successfully placed another 160 children
who applied over the summer in primary
as well as those that went to the fap
um yeah I was just thinking I think I
think it's really important particularly
you well I know you know when we sort
out the year seven applications or or we
allocate okay to place I think what
we've also got to remember is it the
challenge we've got is it may not be the
place that parents want their child to
go to so they have had a place allocated
and that's you know we've met our
statutory responsibility in doing that
the challenge might be where parents
don't want that place and so obviously
they've got the right of appeal and
we're really clear about that and
sometimes there's a weight in terms of
getting and that's subject to the
schools running their appeals panels
um but I think it's kind of two
processes isn't it you've got children
who are coming through fat and then
you've got children who actually have
already been allocated a place but
parents don't want them to to go to that
school so we're kind of managing too too
precious really from from that
perspective
thank you
um if they're in oh oh sorry counselor
[Music]
um thank you can I just ask a couple of
questions
um the the mention of the potential new
school in in the sale area
um obviously
very difficult to find a site in in sale
and you talked about a reduction in the
size of the potential School
would you also factor in potential
growth for that because so it's sort of
future proofing the uh the provisions no
point in designing in a problem it
really needs to be designed out uh and
I'll just ask for a second question and
then let you respond on the um
the the preference in information that
you you you say you've been stressed to
to parents
Diego is Bleak as saying
you know if you don't do it in the
prescribed manner the potential is for
um you know this sort of scenario to to
hammer home because clearly some
parents are are missing the message
um and then uh you know it's they're
throwing their hands up in in horror and
um it's everybody's fault but their own
um so it clearly needs to be a very very
strong message that's going out there
um I'll comment on on the second comment
first so
um we have absolutely made perfectly
clear that message the information that
is on the council website it strongly
encourages parents to consider what will
happen if they do not get a preference
it talks about how many families in each
area relocated schools in different
areas it gives the radius around schools
for some of our non-selective schools
which have shrunk over the years and as
more people live in those catchments so
the advice for the transfer cohort for
2023 which is the applications that are
being made now is a kind of beefed up
version of what we had last year and
we've also got a really strong comms
campaign behind getting that advice out
through digital digital channels as well
as out out by post so
um that's the
stop that that's the answer about the
guidance and just going back to your
other point which was around potential
growth so the scap um requires us to
forecast primary places for five years
ahead and secondary places for seven
years ahead so it is already factoring
in potential growth from all a range of
factors the kind of inbound migration
the new Housing Development so all those
things are factored into the scap
formula and planning and so
a five-form Entry School is you know
it's looking as far ahead as seven years
what we're actually seeing is a
decreasing birth birth rate so what
we're seeing at the other end of the
system is we've got these vacancies in
the reception into the reception year
um and then it's just that that cohort
is growing over time but with the
declining birth rate we you know we
expect this to level out
beyond the seven years that we've
planned for in this Gap
I think this is one of the challenges
with the Scout really unlike our other
GM counterparts because of the selective
system we do have this High rates of of
you know um migration into those upper
year groups so our Prime is almost fill
up from the top down rather than the
bottom up which is what other local
authorities
um are used to and it just kind of adds
another layer the other bit I would say
as well about about the new school and
one thing I do really want to make clear
is that we have been lobbying DFE for a
long long time to get get help us out
with Solutions
um you know we've we've met with them
weekly
um we we've called them we've you know
virtually harassed them really to to
really say look we need support we need
help
um you know this is this is a situation
in Trafford it is unprecedented uh no
Manchester are feeling some of the the
pressures as well
um but it you know we've been really
clear with DFE for a long long time that
that there is an issue and we and we
need support with it so actually you
know the fact that they actually
approached us and said actually we think
we can help you out here um I think is a
real positive and going forward
thank you thank you very much for the
report and oh sorry one last question
I'm sorry it has significant
externalities for our communities not
least issues with with places but
obviously we have transport issues on
the school run
um plus the concerns about safeguarding
for kids going going a long way a long
way away
um you know
we need to know what what those you know
what those implications are you know we
need to know particularly on the you
know the traffic issues that it causes
because you know a lot of the work that
the council was trying to do on traffic
and not are not going to get cured no
matter how many bike Lanes or whatever
you we built you know we we we build the
traffic in in our educational system now
we need to know about that that needs to
be common knowledge and we need to be
talking to our educational system
educational institutions the schools
themselves about the consequences of
their selection
you know their selection policies and
their you know the the choices that they
that they make in at secondary level
because they all control their own their
their own intake what can we do about
that you know to quantify the issues
that they're causing how can we educate
the schools themselves about the courses
that you know what they're doing and
also talk get them talking to us
about doing something about it I mean I
have in my my mind that we really need
you know it may be Blue Sky Thinking or
naive or whatever that we should be
having a you know a kind of a conference
or at least you know some kind of
meeting every year to talk about these
issues you know that are affecting the
community as a whole rather you know
rather than just kind of going well it's
what what's what's always happening it's
always going to happen because we just
have this weird educational assist
grammar educational system here and
that's it you know and we're just stuck
with it forever because we do need to be
dealing we do we need to be dealing with
that and and uh I mean how do we start
how do we get start talking about these
issues rather than just sweeping under
the carpet I mean I mean certainly you
know last week when we had our secondary
fap
um we had the secondary heads uh
conference or standing conference as we
call it
um before that and and we had a
dedicated slot didn't we Sarah where we
presented the hard data so that you know
our grammar school colleagues could see
it as well as as obviously our
non-selective colleagues
um so it is something and I think
because they're now really tangibly
feeling you know the issues that
themselves now when you've got children
you know we one school was quoting that
they're almost 20 children over their
published admissions number in year 10
and and for the teachers amongst us we
know what that is such a challenge in
the year 10 just from a curriculum
organizational point of view you know
there is coming a point where we just
you know the worry is we can't
physically fit these children in anymore
um but the schools have been absolutely
fantastic about how they are rising to
the challenge but we are playing you
know we're playing all of our secondary
colleagues into that conversation to see
how how we can think
to collectively really to solve some of
some of the challenges and the grammar
schools were talking to them about them
being part of the fair access protocol
so that they're able to step up an
entrance exam very quickly to allow some
of our children who are coming in
through fap to sit it so that they can
go to a school very very quickly so
they're not exempt from from fap as well
which is a massive step forward you know
for us in Trafford so you know but but I
agree we're constantly playing all all
of our colleagues in into that that
conversation to see you know together
what Solutions we can come up with but
it is a challenge because the selective
system you know it's it it is a very
specific admissions Criterion and it's
very difficult to work outside of that
thank you thank you very much for the
report and your answers and thank you to
the committee for their questions
um I don't know if you're going to stay
with us for a little while or you're
more than welcome there was just one
point Sorry I meant to make it at the
beginning there was an error in the
report at 6.5
um and it says remains constant at five
percent but it should say decreased over
time from 18 to 16 so I just wanted to
mention that and then we can perhaps
republish the corrected version
um
okay
I'm going to hand over to Jill and
Pamela
um
we have a couple of reports here
um I know you've got slides just gonna
say we're going to take you very much at
your word chair if that's all right and
work on the basis that people have had
the opportunity to have a look at the
slides yeah and to read the the report
my suggestion would be that if the
committee is willing and able to really
see it as a single item the first item
from the slide deck is the latest
um feedback from our monitoring visit
that happened in July the written report
is more of a summary of all of the
issues and the work that we've been
doing since 2019
um I hope the report and the slide deck
speak for themselves I think one of one
of the things that I would just really
want to to pull out is that throughout
the work regardless of whether it's been
a monitoring visit on child in need or a
monitoring visit on our services at the
front door
the approach that we've taken for the
last two and a half years is very much
um if we're doing the right thing for
our children and families then ofsted
takes care of itself really simplistic
approach and belies
um or doesn't really cover all of the
work from a logistics point of view or
managing that process but for us it felt
really really important to take that
approach because I think when I first
came and brought the the leadership team
into being
there was this real tangible sense that
it would be quick it would be easy
because we just needed to have an
improvement plan that ticked the boxes
in terms of what ofsted would saw that
didn't really convey some of the issues
the breadth and depth of the issues and
we really wanted to move from a
tokenistic response to really getting
under the skin of things really
understanding what the issues were so we
moved from an improvement plan an
immediate response to being ambitious
and I think it's absolutely right that
we are ambitious for our children and
families so we do now have an eight
um an eight point ambition plan
we started very much with the basics and
some of the basics are are really very
much that very first page of the 2019
inspection report report that as a
leadership we didn't necessarily
understand what the difficulties were we
didn't understand what the quality of
practice looked like and we didn't
understand what our data was telling us
um the workforce at that point would say
we've been telling you some things
aren't quite right and you're not
listening
so actually part of that Back to Basics
was being data intelligent really
understanding what the quality of our
practice looked like but recognizing
that the most valuable asset that we
have in Trafford are our people
um both our residents that we serve but
equally the workforce that tries to be
helpful to them
a number of the things that we did were
about structuring ourselves organizing
ourselves in a way that made sense to
our children and families organizing
ourselves in a way that meant the job we
were asking or our practitioners or
managers to do was doable
really understanding what quality of
practice looked like
so that whole quality assurance
framework that includes reflective
supervision includes being able to
answer questions on
just as Martina said behind every number
is a child and a family and absolutely
knowing what that meant for our children
and families
our performance Arrangements run from
the leader and the lead member right
down to our teams at a front line and
Pamela very helpfully today has had what
we call her quality and performance
meeting today in which all of the heads
of service brings some narrative about
what's going on in their service the
areas that they're working on but
equally our business intelligent unit
says well actually you're saying that
but the data says this and it enables us
to drill down
one of the things that over the last two
years that I think has
um slightly ironically been helpful
covid has created significant issues but
it's also helped us with that Back to
Basics approach because when we were in
lockdown when we were needing to support
our staff when we were needing to think
about our most vulnerable it really
helped us with some of our partnership
working with our schools in particular
but equally to say to the workforce the
way we know our children are safe and
what's happening for them is we go and
see them we visit them we write it down
we think about what that means in terms
of of Assessments and what we need to do
to be helpful to them
I guess in summary before a hand over to
Palmer for some of the key bits that she
might want to pull out is the biggest
thing that I think we have achieved over
the last couple of years is culture
change and that whole raison Detra that
it is our job to be helpful to our
children and families and actually if we
are doing the right thing for our
children and families if we have that
stability of Workforce if we help our
practitioners to be the best that they
possibly can be that inspection is just
an external validation process
pamelas don't know what you want to come
in on and then we're happy to take
questions
yeah I'll I'll just give them a few
kaneki overviews from my perspective
really I think one of the the key things
which has been quite unusual in
trafford's Improvement Journey from
Improvement Journeys I've done elsewhere
is that in none of the four monitoring
visits and one Assurance visit that
we've had have they formally referred
any cases of children to us that they
are concerned about that they are
potentially at risk or they're not
comfortable with the direction that
we're going in and I think that you know
doesn't come across in the monitoring
visit letters but I think that's a
really important point to assure people
that again in this visit they didn't
raise any children that they felt that
were in child in need that shouldn't be
in child in need that should be perhaps
in child protection or or or higher so
that's really reassuring for us clearly
still a lot to do still a way to go in
terms of that consistency and we are
working with each manager to to put in
place what we're calling an
amplification plan what are the three
key issues that you're going to be
working on for the next three months to
focus on that quality of practice that's
going to really make a difference for
children and the quality of the work
that we're doing with children and so
those plans will be coming into a
meeting that Jill and I have with with
all of our heads of service and practice
managers on Thursday afternoon head of
our Improvement board in in a few weeks
um I think some of the the positives to
highlight are around that stable
leadership team that has um a real um
self-aware uh and um accurate self view
we do have
um
a higher rate of interim workers than we
would want but a significant number of
those interim workers have been with us
for a significant amount of time and are
offering some stability for children and
assessments some are detailed and
analytical but some are are weaker and
so that variability is coming in there
in assessments and a similar picture for
plans and management all this aren't
really so a number of positives I think
that the verbal feedback that we receive
from from inspectors
um feels much more positive than when
you receive the Written Letter and for
all sorts of reasons
um but clear clearly a lot still for us
to do and we're not accomplished and we
know we're not there yet but we we are
making progress I'm going in the right
direction
I just wondered as well whether it might
be helpful for committee to get some
context in terms of what the regional
picture looks like so in terms of um
I've got the the information for 21 out
of the 23 North West local authorities
and in terms of of what that looks like
the majority of local authorities their
children's services have been rated as
requires Improvement so there's
currently 10 local authorities that are
requires Improvement there's currently
five local authorities in the Northwest
that are rated as inadequate and that
includes one local Authority where every
judgment and sub-judgment is inadequate
obviously ours was in in overall and
leadership and management there are only
six local authorities out of the
Northwest 23 that half good as their
overall judgment
I don't say that to make any excuses
because like I say we're highly
ambitious for our children and families
and I think it's fundamentally too
important to get wrong so whatever the
outcome of our next inspection activity
is we will always strive for better but
I just think it's quite helpful in terms
of that contextualization it's a
difficult space to work in and we have
to make some difficult decisions with
actually doing the right thing for our
children and families has to be the
raise on Detra for what we're doing
thank you
foreign thank you both
um very reassuring
um does anybody have any questions
three lots of
um
that's it that's in relation to the RR
is the rapid review process that any
agency can refer
um to our safeguarding Partnership if
they think there is a missed opportunity
or a concern we have to hold a rapid
review if a if a child has died
cspr is the child safeguarding practice
review there used to be the serious case
review so apologies for the acronyms in
that
um
so
um what was the last one that you asked
about
graded care profile too so the greater
care profile is a tool that has been
devised by the nspcc that's been rolled
out nationally it's been updated and it
now has a second version
um I think when we had our last
Improvement board I shared a little
anecdote of something that had happened
at the National Association of directors
of children's services conference that
was talking about intersectionality that
was talking about neglect and there was
a slide that the speaker put up in
relation to neglect and it was a picture
of a child with a massive blonde hair
playing
um in their house the playing was with a
cardboard box a wooden spoon they had
some of the factors that are listed in
the creative care profile too so does a
child have access to a hot meal to food
do they have toys to play with
um is their hair tidy and brushed on a
daily basis and this picture was of a
little child like I say cardboard box
wooden spoon wooden spoon you might be
able to say do they can they cook and
the the punch line was who do we think
that was
and the punchline is it was a picture of
Boris Johnson as a child so that that
and I guess the reason for sharing that
little anecdote is a tool is only as
good as the analysis and the
interpretation of what's that
information telling you what do you
understand about that child's lift
experience so we do have some issues
about whether across the children's
system people are using the graded care
profile to to identify potential neglect
at an early stage but the critical bit
is what do we understand about what we
need to do to be helpful for that child
and family
thank you does anybody have any
questions
what hindrance are you find in with the
service improvement plan by the lack of
qualified social workers that are
looking for permanent employment you
know we know how many agency stuff
you're working with and does that impact
the speed that you wish to go up
I think it did initially but I think
we've got to a position where
um we are as Pamela articulated seeing
greater stability within even our
interim Workforce we've done a lot of
work both in Trafford and across the
Northwest to understand the reasons why
people might be working as agency and we
have opened up all of our training all
of our strengthening practice program
which is more than just a training
program it is about embedding our
practice model to all of our staff
regardless of whether they're on
short-term contracts permanent contracts
or agency staff because at the end of
the day they are the workforce that are
working with our children and families
so we think it's really really important
that
um they are the best that they possibly
can be
we did experience quite significant
turnover and some of that was linked to
our service redesign and some of that
was linked to the fact
um that some agency staff were jumping
from one place to another but the fact
that we've invested in them in their
developments as well but being really
clear about the standards that we expect
from practice we have seen that
stability
the other thing I was waiting for
councilor Maitland to ask about this the
other thing that we've been working on
is across the Northwest and within GM on
trying to stabilize
um through having a not-for-profit
approach to agency so we've done a big
survey that's been externally
um run to look at the factors why people
might be interim and then to work on
devising a Model as to whether we could
have a not-for-profit agency
um approach the second strand that we've
got to that is
um working on
um some work that's actually happened in
London through a pledge whereby all of
the local authorities
pledge to not go above agreed agency
rates to look at Equalization of
permanent staff rates
um to look at not pinching staff from
one another to look at agreed quality
markers so actually taking different
approaches to how we can tackle and
manage the market because you're right
you know if you've got a constant
turnover of Staff or if you've got
people that aren't really committed to
you as a place or a locality or the
organizational values it it is going to
hinder improvements
um but we are seeing some real inroads
and I think it comes from
um being absolutely persistent in terms
of our investing in our people strategy
exacting in our standards and
understanding the quality of people's
work regardless of their employment
status
and I'll just just add to that if I may
that we we have had some success as well
with our interim workers converting to
become permanent workers and some of
those have progressed as well into
advanced practitioner and practice
manager roles which is really positive
and it goes back to
um I think it's the last line in the
monitoring letter which says that um the
staff that was spoken to like working in
Trafford and case loads are manageable
and that's a huge um pull factor
um for people coming here and staying
here
thank you councilor Maitland
thank you for answering that without me
I I it's because I'd already spoke to
councilor Hines about it I've got some
answers
um
regarding the audits
um
I think there's a comment here but some
audits are still found to like adequate
analysis
um and to be too task orientated and
then we've got that the practice of
moderation isn't isn't consistent either
what what's getting in that way of it
moving forward
I think there's a couple of things that
um we have had some new managers join us
so we have to go back through the
induction process of audit is not just a
tick box it's actually an in-depth look
at the work it's a helpful tool because
it helps you understand how your worker
is practicing
um we've also had
um some instances where the words on the
page just like the written recording
about a visit don't reflect the depth of
the conversation so one of the things
that Pamela and I have introduced is us
doing what I would call a cold order
literally just having the piece of paper
not looking at the case recording on the
system but just saying these are the
words I'm seeing on the page this is
what it's telling me so an example would
be
um I looked this week at some personal
supervision
and that the manager was clearly worried
about their practitioners emotional
well-being there was a whole paragraph
on building works that she was having
done to her house it went into great
depth about the stud wall being knocked
out another wall being built up all of
this kind of thing but it didn't get to
the punch line to say I'm really worried
about Jill or Jill's finding it hard to
work at home so we've discussed X number
of strategies so we're constantly
needing to work with people not to be
literate in terms of what have you seen
you know child scene yes hey yes but
what you understand from that how how
can you be helpful to your practitioner
to inform the practice we've had to do a
whole hearts and Minds piece about why
quality assurance why all that matters
so that whole approach of back to Bases
right you see children you write down
that you've seen them actually and I
want you to add breadth and depth and
meaning to it and it's the same for the
audit process so if we're being honest
if you think back to 2019
we had done
I think it was one thematic audit in a
six-month period
ofsted are really clear with this
achieved volume with a tree we've
achieved it happening systematically for
some of the audits they offer a real
richness of what that quality of
practice looks like for some we've got a
little bit more to do so hearts and
minds and getting to that says it's not
just seen as a management task
if you ask the managers they would
probably say the biggest issue is is
time so we're creating the time and
space and saying it's not an add-on to
your job it is the day job
do you want to come in with anything
yeah we've we've put in place a body and
up Arrangement as well because you know
in in in Social care there will always
be something else that's screaming loud
for your time as a manager and and so
we've bodied managers up to say you
cover for each other to create that time
to to do your audience because what was
happening I think was they were getting
to the end of the month as they would do
and then trying trying to get them them
done really quickly we've not live not
the depth
um there was some really good examples
of
um in in the audience that we put
forward of contacting family members and
one manager had spoken to a mom and a
young person about the quality of Social
Work she didn't turn me in that in those
words in the conversation but had a
really lengthy conversation about how
helpful the social worker had been so we
are getting some some good examples and
getting that depth from actually the the
experts who over vex experience the
service but that's not embedded across
aren't you am I on still can I just
any day they could come in now and do a
full inspection
are you confidential I'm confident that
we're not inadequate whether we'd get
um some of those sub-judgments to be
good I think it will depend on the
amplification plans it will depend on
the cases that they pick I'm confident
that we've got a really solid base but
you know I'm not sitting here being
naive to say we are not an inadequate
Children's Services have we cracked
everything no we haven't have we got
more to do yes is there too much
variability yes there probably is have
we got an accurate self-assessment yes
we have are we clear about the areas
that we need to improve yes have we got
a Workforce that are working with us yes
we have so we've got some really really
solid foundations I think the other bit
that I'll come back to before carol runs
out the room is I think one of the areas
that we have worked really hard on is
both internally and externally to to put
Children and Families the center and to
work on a partnership basis some of the
working with our schools Now is really
exceptional and it's not seen as an
education service and a children's
social care service we want service and
we don't always get it right and
sometimes our schools will say we're
telling you we're really worried about
this family you're not listening
an example would be rdfe Improvement
advisor and chair of our Improvement
board this week spent some time at our
front door and last week wasn't it not
this week and she was so positive and if
you think back to 2019 in terms of the
front door that contact referral that
reach out that was one of the areas
apart from the leadership and management
that ofsted were most worried about she
thought there was some exceptional
features about it she thought the way
that we were regulating and being
responsive she described the work with
our education advisor or domestic abuse
advisor and all police colleagues with
our social care colleagues as a single
team and working as a single team you
can never say never and you can never
say you know something comes out the
blue but
from the audits that we've seen from the
data that we've seen from the
conversations from the external
validation that we have
I don't think we're inadequate
so I've got councilor Hornby has the
question and then a final question from
the councilor Blackburn
say that I thought it was absolutely
great to see that ofsted had noted that
practitioners
um liked working in Trafford and I think
it's really something to celebrate and I
just wanted to ask for a bit more detail
about the not-for-puffer agency and how
that's progressing I just have a
personal interest in that I'm really
keen on the idea and and I think it
really will help decrease our Reliance
on agency workers
I think it's one of those things that's
probably in the medium term so the first
phase was actually to scope across all
23 of the Northwest local authorities
what the reasons were were why people
did work for agency rather than want the
security I think there's some things
that were surprising that came out of
that survey work and some things that
weren't surprising and I think one of
the things that has further compounded
the issue is the pandemic itself because
people have got used to different ways
of working haven't they they've got used
to a far greater flexibility you know
people can work very much remotely but
actually social work is a business where
you need to be able to go and see people
and you need to have the support of
colleagues around you that first phase
is finished we're now in a second phase
of scoping and the scoping is if we want
if we had a viable partner that wanted
to work with us across the 20 three is a
not-for-profit
um partner what would the logistics of
that look like how would you host those
staff how would you employ them how
would you deploy them to areas of need
so we're in that logistical testing and
thinking about what those options will
be they'll come back to the DCS group
I don't know off the top of my head the
the time scale for that but as I'm sure
you can imagine just even the logistics
of how do you service 23 of us
and deploy a limited resource in a way
it does take some logistical working out
but I think the fact that we've
attracted DFE money to help with this
second phase and the pilot think of it
shows that there is National interest in
what we're doing
brilliant thank you
um and one last question I could have
just asked on the priorities moving
forward to do with the workforce the
complex needs team it says that external
support book will be required to support
us what will that entail
so our children with additional needs is
a is a service that has had significant
instability it's a very small team it's
very niche in terms of the work and the
needs of those children and one of the
things that we think has been
um that we need to think about is what
does the skill mix for that social work
team need to look like from a Health and
Care perspective so we're really wanting
to bring together
um the partners from across the system
to think about what the skill set is
we have just
um got a new practice manager albeit on
an interim basis come and join us we
have
um also had some success in one of our
um Advanced practitioners choosing to
move into that service so we wanted a
little bit of challenge a little bit of
support and we're wanting to bring
together agencies from a car across the
Health and Care system to really think
about how we strengthen and build up
sort of permanent positions or will it
be temporary until until that section's
stabilized
at the moment we've got an established
structure some of those posts are filled
by agency interim staff some are filled
by permanent staff but the work that I'm
talking about is thinking about do we
need everybody in that team to be Social
Work qualified or do we need some people
with nursing expertise for example
actually how do we integrate with rot
our occupational therapy our physical
physiotherapy teams what does that look
like thinking about the the needs of the
children that that team works with
attention thank you thank you both
um did you want to clear Cath
yeah
all right but thank you it's very
reassuring and we have come on a long
journey but I feel as though we're
certainly we are going in the right
direction so yeah we are aren't we
thank you
sorry
um I think the report speaks for itself
does anybody have any comments or
questions okay
yeah thanks sister
it's coming right at the last minute um
it's great that
the best thing about this report is that
it shows that the program is up and
running again this year which um but
that means we really now need to focus
on the previous three years two
the current year eights and year nines
missed out during covert and the current
year sevens missed out because the
program
basically just didn't happen last year
didn't function
um
and the program it says here that the um
transport for greater Manchester are
working with bike rights to try and
capture at senior School these children
who missed out at Primary School the
scheme is called own the ride
um as far as I'm aware this has
consisted of basically that one traffic
telling the schools that this is
available but obviously most secondary
schools are not have never had anything
to do with providing bikeability for
their children now I've managed to get
one school Wellington to provide us a
really strong program for um for for
their their year eights as far as I'm
aware at the moment that's the only
school that has put anything on
um you know
this has to be promoted to the secondary
schools as an as an opportunity and
something that we're actually really
advocating if it's going to happen you
know otherwise you know we're just
basically saying well the potential's
there for it to happen it can happen but
it's not our responsibility anymore
because they've all left primary school
but we've got three years of children
the vast majority of which haven't had
the only formal bike training that
they've ever had so what I would like to
you know if we were to ask another
question on this which is for the
committee to decide is is to how are we
monitoring you know and we did pass it
we did pass a motion at Council last
year saying that we were going to try
and provide you know provide those
children with catch-up bikeability how
are we going to monitor how you know how
many schools are getting involved in
doing that and providing that
bikeability and how many of the you know
and how many of those
yeah and how many children who have
missed out have had that kind of that
catch up training you know this is a
point at which we can go either we can
wash our hands of it and say right it's
not our business anymore because they're
not in Primary School
um you know and most of those children
will miss out because you know if if
this isn't properly promoted to the
secondary schools and it kind of given a
sense of this we really want you to do
this this is a requirement
um
uh the other so that there's there's
that the other thing is that this talks
about
um uh bikeability being a free stage
program these days now we're only
providing key stage one and two stage
three should be should be provided in a
secondary school and it's actually
probably the most important stage
because stage three takes children up to
um or should we say young adults um
because you know it should be provided
sort of for uh at the age of 13 to 16 or
so it provides children with um
teenagers with the ability to not just
ride a bike safely for a bit on the road
but also to to teach us them how to uh
for example plan a journey so you you'll
get experience planning a journey from a
to you know A to B
um and you know getting there safely map
reading skills and those kind of things
which is really important for the
independence of our young people if
they're getting about and particularly
getting about sustainable fashion so
that's a question to what that we could
ask in terms of what is the count you
know what bike abilities expanded to you
know it's got an extra stage currently
kids in in our in our Borough aren't
getting it
is that something we can look at doing
you know is the funding there from the
government if if so how do we go about
structuring
um you know accessing that funding and
running that running that scheme
um yes sorry I've said enough I'm sure
that as a group a screw stick of it or
as
Council we can actually impose this on
secondary schools
the promotion of it and I'm just
wondering who will be able to provide us
with those figures of
um
how many children are affected how many
would be interested how many have taken
up this own the right scheme um it would
have to come I would imagine from
Individual schools would it
I'm not quite sure there I don't know if
tfdm would be tracking that or if it's
uh our team but the question can be put
to our team one I did speak to them and
they were putting the report together
they did so they were they thought that
through tfgm the goal was to have to
catch up by September next year but I
don't know where the figures that they
had or where that expectation came from
but I can ask um is that something we
could request Alex please
let's look at them
um I I do have my
decisions proficiency badge thank you
I'm not wearing it now however it does
exist
um I'm just wondering I I don't I know
very little about this I'm just
wondering in terms of encouraging
schools to take it up
weather and you perhaps will know this
whether it links into the things that
schools
um that sort of soft curriculum that
schools are trying to do around
citizenship health and well-being you
know potential links for geography
technical stuff and whether or not that
side of it is being made enough of to
make schools think it is worth the
timetable time
um so I know a lot of schools are
looking at trying to
um demonstrate that they are putting
time and effort into those sort of
personal development skills and I think
that this has got a lot to offer in
terms of personal development you know
in terms of encouraging children to
travel independently which you do on the
whole on the bike
um I'm just wondering if it's been sold
well enough or if it's just been sort of
like a a standalone activity that takes
up valuable lesson time
so I'm wondering whether the program
sells itself enough to schools and I
don't know the answer to that because
it's interesting slides
um
maybe
if we're going to get some figures
hopefully maybe we could ask about the
promotion how it's been promoted how
it's being sold how it's how it's been
packaged really as a sort of a you know
should say part of well it's very it's
potentially very
as well as like I say um you know that
in that personal development for
children which a lot of schools are
looking for ways to develop
um so it seems to me that if they could
justify the time given over to it
because it will be time out of lessons
um it might help people take it up
better
we could get some more info
yeah
um could I just ask a question for the
answer to come at a later time if the
program operates during the academic
year but funding is Run for the
financial year does funding carry over
or is the funding lost because I know
that there's um
1242 children booked out of
2362 training places and that's books
before the end of January so have those
places to be to be filled by the end of
March or you know beginning of big I
know it'll be whoever it'll be one
Trafford who will answer that could
could I'll leave that with you Alex
thank you
hi I just had a question
um councilor Walton raised last time
about the fact that there was possible
staff shortages to actually deliver the
program
um and in the report it says that
currently we have two contractors on
board with the third potentially coming
on board in the future as well as our
own staff but I don't think that's clear
as whether we are we have enough stuff
to deliver the program or not because it
doesn't say how many you need to help
how many stuff you need to deliver it or
anything it just is that perhaps some
information we can request from
um one Trafford that would be around it
thank you
okay yeah cancel that yeah I was going
to ask that question but you beat me to
it but
um yeah I just wanted to make the note
really that I also passed my proficiency
chess
not yesterday
it was uh when I was 11 I think it was
and I got a nice flag Penance and I'll
put that on my back obviously there
wasn't as many cars on the road those
days so I probably wouldn't have passed
but it's I think it's my own my only
qualification from school but I'm very
proud of it
I just wanted to ask as well if um I'm
not sure if this will be possible or not
but if we can see the data of like who's
doing it on a ward level or even if it's
School per word like what you know where
the gaps are I think I'm wanting to know
really
I'm very conscious of time and I've got
another urgent item but
um the last word so at the the
Wellington program
um was delivered as alongside the P the
PE curriculum so that was uh you know it
was the head teacher kind of worked with
his Department there
um to to do that I mean I think
um the year it's very much been seen as
a year six thing and a kind of like in
one of those kind of end of primary
school rituals and that has made sense
in in the sense that it's going through
to um you know you the kids are going to
secondary school so you're kind of
preparing them hopefully for riding to
school and things like that but I think
this if you look on is it worth having a
look at the bikeability
um web page because it goes into a lot
of detail about you know the broadening
of this of this curriculum so they are I
mean they they offer programs from the
very you know from the eyfs stage
getting kids on balance bikes because
it's very much about getting you know if
you get kids on the balance bike at a
very early age they can ride basically
so and you don't get that drop off
because the problem is with the year
with the year six is if a kid can't
balance on a bike they can't do the bike
ability so they're already out of the
pro the out of the program
um the great so um you know and uh so
it's about getting it as a continual
thing throughout education and that's
how we kind of build a build our own
sort of mini piloton of uh you know of
children in Trafford and hopefully I
mean it might be something that we want
to ask we could ask that whether it's
something that that could be addressed
in the walking and cycling strategy
which I know
um I mean I'm sure it does mention that
in in a bit but it might be something we
want to make sure is
um address properly in that yeah
thank you all right thank you so I'll
leave you with the I was just gonna say
okay let's double check I've got all the
things that people want to ask
um so
um action to the main one was to monitor
the numbers we've missed out and um how
many have caught up and who's monitoring
it uh then
um school around funding and whether how
it worked with um the program's been run
on school year and then funding's been
done by uh Financial year and councilor
Hornby um it was about the level of
staff and whether it's adequate yeah uh
and then you again
um so it's a breakdown of uh take up by
Ward so you could see where the gaps
were in the area and then the final one
was um whether it links into the walk-in
and cycling strategy is that everything
great yeah thanks Alex
right can I um come on to item nine and
go off and have
um an item of um urgent business but
this has been put to us it's come from
the um Health Group committee it's
something I myself have been trying to
look at for a number of years now so
we're looking at cams now it does need
all the criteria for scrutiny
um in that
um
obviously it's children young people's
mental health
um
I think Kobe kovic kovid can't even say
it has um had a huge impact on a lot of
our children and young people
um so
you know it needs to be a priority area
it's a key issue for the public January
um and I think that qualifies it we have
a new system now for bringing things to
scrutiny and what I'm looking for is um
anybody that will be interested in
forming a task and finish group I'm
going to put my name down because I've
been trying to get this off the ground
for three years now
um I don't know if anybody else would be
interested
um if you if you are could you let
either myself or Alex no I don't know if
anybody from Health would be interested
at all Mike as well as soon as it's gone
from there well that's the idea is that
it would be a joint be a joint yeah that
would be great yeah effort and that
would actually help us
um
schedule another piece of work as well
yeah so there's some quite good uh
efficiencies and synergies to to be
achieved here if we could link up with
that I know um Health scrutiny did
something on camps I think it was in
2016.
um
I've got the report somewhere
in my office but yeah it'd be
interesting what I would like to look at
to see what improvements are otherwise
they've followed from that being now
it's uh six years on so yeah certainly
something but do let us know if you're
interested Denise could I just quickly
really quickly ask
um
is it specifically I'm not a member of
the committee and I'm not you know not
not saying I am but I just wanted to
specifically around Cam's provision or
is it mental health provision for
children and young people more I think
healthy young minds now so I think I
think it's um
around it I mean covet has affected
across you know from Tiny Tots who have
missed out so much on that early years
development right through to adults and
you know
senior citizens and everybody
everybody's mental health yeah impacted
in some way so broadly peace and if we
look at it from a children's under
Health aspect
I'm just wondering about it actually
about that particular point so access to
Children young people's Mental Health
Services following a pandemic
um I think that sort of limits the remit
a little bit I think what it might be
just opening it up a little bit to take
access to John and young people's Mental
Health Services it might be that during
the course of that investigation we do
look at that comparison but I wouldn't
like that to be the ultimate pain
because that's quite a static it's a
static moment in time thing isn't it
yeah and also I am quite interested in
sitting on the task and finish but I
wonder Alex in that case
um if you could
I'm remembering that there are a couple
of things coming up in so there was a
campus thing in London
yeah and something else I think
was it calm connections it says there's
a national cams
um convention I think coming up yeah
that um places are available for is that
is that what you mean yeah so I was just
wondering I had a feeling of something
going on with Stratford armdale as well
about
um I will have a look through my emails
um which you're always interested in but
you're trying to focus on stuff that
you're dealing with aren't you but
obviously if we're going to sit on the
task and finish group those things might
be interesting so I just wondered if you
could just reiterate those things to the
scrutiny and health I know they're a
member of the children's committee has
asked she's
um the members interested in going down
to that's the course in London isn't it
um
don't know how many will be out I
unfortunately can't because I'm quite
interested I'd be more interested if
somebody was going because I like
someone told me yeah but somebody is
coming hopefully
oh sorry sorry I was just going to add
um
ghost Hill studios I've actually done a
piece of work about this with an
organization called people's voice media
where they've been collecting dots from
children about their effects of the
pandemic and also from youth workers so
it might be worth you're looking at that
as part of of the outcomes of that and
to inform it that's interesting it's
something that's been raised as well we
have um each year at and children's
scrutiny I've invited the students from
Trafford college and it's something that
they have raised
um in the last two or three years it has
had a bit a big impact on them as well
so I think everything could you know if
it all ties in together
um
we can hopefully get some a good piece
of work done
okay so there's no more questions I'm
going to close the meeting I do
apologize if I have run over a bit but I
think we've had some really interesting
topics this evening
um so thank you all for attending she
was safer than you know